you I woke up to huge news this morning
and
uh first thing I saw when I went on
Twitter well there were two things
trending when I went on the first thing
in the morning I saw Miami
mall and
aliens and I knew immediately what that
meant I didn't need to do any more
research I I saw it and I was like okay
well Ali aliens landed and they went to
a mall in Miami obviously it's what
happened and sure enough that is exactly
what happened and we have evidence we
have proof and we'll get to it but
here's the report from Newsweek uh an
incident at a Miami shopping mall which
resulted in the arrest of four teenagers
earlier this week has sparked the spread
of a bizarre this is their word bizarre
theory on social media which suggests
that the alleged presence of aliens at
the Florida establishment more than 60
police cars swarm the Bayside
Marketplace in downtown Miami on Monday
night to shut down a fight involving a
group of teenagers who were also
throwing fireworks at each other in the
open air shopping mall for teenagers
were arrested in connection to the
incident according to the uh suspect's
arrest reports mentioned by the
television station the juveniles were
causing a riot inside the mall and
causing panic okay so that's the
official story that there was a
fight at a
mall when's the last time you heard of a
fight at a mall in Miami of all places I
don't think so so immediately you hear
that think something else is going on
here that doesn't sound right and that's
when you go and you well where am I
going to find the truth I'm not going to
find it from these corporate media
Outlets uh so I got to go to Tik Tok and
Tik Tok is on the case and various
independent journalists on Tik Tok um
have been reporting that in fact there
were giant aliens at the mall and and
that's what caused the disturbance so
here's one video from a woman on Tik Tok
who's kind of breaking it all down and
giving us the the the basic facts of the
case let's watch
that the Miami Police was not dispat bed
there for a juvenile fight and the
obvious need for such an enormous police
presence was far more Sinister than what
we've been told as multiple Witnesses
claimed to have seen I can't believe I'm
going to say this creatures that stood 8
to 10 ft tall walking outside and even
inside of the mall and the Pew pews that
were reported and even the Pew pews you
might hear in some of the videos had
nothing to do with the juvenile fight
according to these Witnesses it was
actually the mg goers shooting to
protect themselves from these 8 to 10t
tall creatures in
self-defense
now that's all you need to hear really
10 foot tall aliens at the mall people
shooting at
them she told you about it that's it why
would she lie about
it why would this woman whoever she is
lie about this there's no reason that I
can think of and so it's it's
essentially impossible that she lied but
if you are skeptical and you're saying
oh well she wasn't
there um okay well let's listen to
someone who was there and gives an
eyewitness report of what he
encountered um and this is pretty
disturbing I warn you but let's listen
to what he has to
say since nobody's going to talk about
it I fig you know like you know what I'm
saying I was uh I was down in Miami for
uh the New Year's you know what I'm
saying me and my girl I got a little
time share we was down there on the um
like a mini vacay you know just to start
the New Year's off right so anyway we
had we happened to be at that mall so um
we had foot lock or whatever next thing
you know you start hearing all this
commotion outside sound like fire like
firecrackers or something so you know
what I'm saying I you know I grab a
close I'm like we about to get out of
here cuz I you know I originally thought
that they was shooting you know what I'm
saying I thought you know some type of
um gunfight had broke out whatever the
case is cuz you know we're not familiar
with Miami we not familiar with the city
so I'm like damn I ain't even got my bck
so you know saying we about to we about
to about to Swerve next thing I know
it's like crazy like we just see all
these people running like you know uh
fat fat fat chicks you know old ladies
like I'm talking about moving you know
what I'm saying like yo old people even
move I'm talking about moving so you
know my girl she like what's going on
I'm like we out like I'm not going to
ask no questions we just going to follow
the crowd next thing you know you know
real like gunshots start going off so
you know what I'm saying like we trying
to we trying to follow the follow the
crowd get out here I look back I look
back no cap Yo No Cap I look back it
looked like like like a big ass Shadow
but it was solid at the same time like a
few like a few Shadows but they was
solid at the same time and it almost
looked like they was coming our
Direction like they was chasing
us there it is no cap he said it himself
no cap and you might think oh this is
Cap but he's saying no it's not there's
no son's cap there's no
cap and uh 10 foot tall alien Shadows
Shadow aliens have landed and they went
to Foot Locker um think about the thing
that really sticks out to me about his
testimony is he said that fat chicks
were running and now you tell me why
else would a fat chick run have you ever
seen a fat chick run if they were in the
habit of running they wouldn't be
fat so you think well why would they be
running were they giving free samples at
cinnabun that'd be one reason cinnabun
doesn't give free samples okay I've
asked so that's out you narrow down the
list must be aliens now I will say I've
been told that the guy who made that
video has since come out and said that
it's a hoax and he didn't he didn't
really see anything but that that just
proves even more because they got to him
you know he said what he saw and then
later comes out and says oh I was just
kidding yeah right of course he would
say that after he gets the knock on the
door you know and the the the SUV pull
up and they tell him you better you
better take that back Mister that's what
the FBI probably said but here's the
part where you're saying oh well if
there were really aliens at the mall why
didn't anyone get them on video and I I
hate this talking point because I've
talked about this before you know this
idea that well why are they on video do
you really think that if you were being
chased by 10ft tall Shadow aliens from
Neptune or whatever that you would take
a second to pull your phone out you're
running for your life you've left your
Foot Locker purchases behind you haven't
even taken those and you're going to
have time you're going to think wa while
what are you going to backpedal while
you're running that doesn't make any
sense but as it happen someone did get
the aliens on film so this uh particular
video has gone gone viral and where you
can actually see let's play this you can
actually see the the
aliens you can see him
somewhere oh right
there look at
that was that it yeah that was
it so okay I think that well we only
need to see it once did did you someone
who who apparently had a camera phone
like this person happened to have the
first camera phone ever made in history
and uh and but they got footage of of an
alien and he's like this a smudge he's a
he looks like a smudge it's a smudge
alien uh and the other guy said it's a
shadow alien so these are the aliens
themselves are blurry that kind of
answers the question why why every time
we see an alien on camera they're blurry
it's because the aliens are literally
blurry
themselves last question you ask is well
why do the aliens go to the mall seems
like an odd place to go that's not hard
to explain think about it you've been in
a spaceship for thousands of years is
probably uh you just land
here they probably need to pick up some
supplies like they need to get out
stretch their legs and uh they need to
pick up some supplies like they probably
like
toiletries um maybe a quick snack
there's probably an alien who forgot his
jacket you know I know with my kids we
go on a trip and and as soon as we get
there there's always at least one kid
who's like I forgot a shoe so not both
shoes you forgot one shoe right on my
jacket and so you got to you got to go
what do you have to do you have to go to
the mall because you don't know where
else to go and you go to the mall and
you have to buy this thing so I could
see something like that might have
happened with these aliens and next
thing you know they're being shot at um
and uh and so what was a peaceful jaunt
to uh the mall by these aliens has now
become the beginning of uh the
destruction of our
planet
thankfully if You' like to see what else
I have to say you can access my full
show by going to dailywire or by going
to the Matt wall Show Twitter page hope
to see you there godp speed